hazard zone is battlefield 2042's new
squad based competitive mode and it
honestly sounded pretty complicated on
the dice blog but it's really not at the
most basic level it's about finding hard
drives and getting out on an aircraft
alive but there's also a ton of ways to
do that and we're here to help you out
with what we learned so far hit that
subscribe button bang on the old thumbs
up and let's dive into hazard zone
number one start early seriously if you
think this is your jam don't wait to
play hazard zone that's because you
currently start with zero dark market
credits that's the currency used to buy
weapons and powerful upgrades before
each round earned from the previous
round that means if you start late you
risk getting rolled by fully kitted
teams who've been playing for a while
that's one of the things that makes this
not like battle royale you do start each
round with stuff number two grunt
farming is a viable strategy if you just
ignored that first tip there's more than
one way to earn dark market credits and
data drives aren't worth as much as you
might think if you die before extracting
with hard drives you lose those points
but you still keep what you earn from
killing opposing forces the enemy bots
and also other enemy teams for free you
can even equip the negotiated bounty one
perk that gives you fifty percent more
returns for grunt farming as a matter of
fact if you're just going to extract
with a few hard drives you can probably
make as much by just fighting since
there's only eight other teams it could
be a viable strategy to just go hunt
them down and take the drives that they
drop
number three when you come across
satellites or an opposing force you
might want to hang back and see what
happens like in any battle royale ish
mode you can and will get third partied
at the worst possible time number four
bring ammo ammo management is
challenging across most of the major
modes in 2042 and if you start fights
you will run out either buy ammo crates
at the start of rounds bring angel or
just be very mindful of when to break
off and save your ammo for an extraction
i did run out several times another tip
is to buy weapons at the start of each
round that come with different ammo
types because each magazine has its own
ammo count so if you run out of one type
you have backups another great way to
save ammo is to let boris's turret and
ranger do some of the work for you when
it comes to killing opposing forces
number five some specialists can work a
little different in hazard zone like
angel who can't seem to do his one thing
dropping a crate that lets you swap
loadouts because you don't have multiple
loadouts in these matches that being
said specialists do have some major
advantages boris's sentry turret is not
great at killing but it's fantastic at
alerting you to enemies around you and
could keep you from getting third
partied all about that situational
awareness
number six on the topic of loadouts make
sure you get your guns out in the plus
system because you're really buying your
own weapons at the start of each round
that means the more unlocked your guns
are from all out warfare the better they
are in hazard zone number seven pack a
dmr or get yourself with a gun that's
good at range a lot of these maps are
huge with long sight lines so good
snipers are probably going to grow
dominant in hazard zone be one of them
number eight buy insurance at the start
of every round you can buy more than
just guns you can actually buy insurance
which gives you back some of your dark
market credits at the end of a round
although i have to say in our experience
one big win will carry you several
rounds afterwards number nine be on mic
although update you'll have to be on
discord or other services until voice
chat is actually added into the game
later on i seriously can't imagine this
mode without a coordinated squad the
ping system is pretty good at calling
out specific info like what you spotted
the direction and the range but it just
can't make up for the kind of
communication you need in an actual
fight like when to hold back or when to
push a team that's weak it also just
can't do things like conversations you
need to have like should you go to the
first condor or wait for the second
games like warzone have made huge
strides for solo players in recent years
and hazard zone just doesn't have a solo
rando friendly environment at least at
launch another thing to keep in mind
though if you're communicating is
there's a pretty good compass now which
you can use for good call outs number 10
vehicles are both power and risk this
will be a few points on vehicles but
vehicles in 2042 are very strong in
multiple modes and that's no different
for hazard zone calling in some kind of
fast transport vehicle that has a gun on
top can make or break around you can
literally just roll up on squads that
are unprepared and demolish them number
11 make sure someone on your team is an
anti-vehicle specialist like sundance or
bring a rocket it will save you number
12 which is why no squad should all pile
into one vehicle seriously just don't do
it your game might end real fast if you
get hit but in a pinch if you all have
to pile into one truck you can get
creative but dozer in the flatbed with
his shield out to protect your team's
back also riding in the flap out of the
truck is the only way to shoot enemy
teams chasing you you can't turn around
in the front seats number 13 calling the
dogs and more the call and tablet is
just as powerful here as it is in all
out warfare as you roam the map you'll
find things like ranger call-ins team
respawn uplinks and vehicle drops your
team can call in multiple rangers at
once and they'll follow you for the rest
of the match they're fantastic at
alerting you of enemy teams and opposing
forces nearby but on the other side of
that rangers are really bad at stealth
and they'll alert everyone to your
presence by shooting at anything that
moves even at pretty far distances we
haven't found a way to tell them to just
not
found danger 260 degrees
14 let's talk about extractions for
starters you can't blow up the condor we
did ask you should though always assume
there's an enemy team already inside we
won a couple of matches when other teams
strolled up to the condor unaware we
were in there so if you're approaching
one always throw a grenade or fire a
rocket into it first that or use one of
the wall hack characters like pake to
scan the condor before entering number
15 you can't plug the doorway with dozer
shield or irish's barricade we tried it
and it seemed kind of buggy it didn't
work for some reason but it's a great
idea to leave boris's turret or irish's
barricade outside for some added cover
number 16 don't forget to have someone
hang back if you have a lot to lose
while you're playing keep looking for
squad redeploy uplinks around the map
they can be used to bring your squad
back to life through the calling tablet
if you're on a streak and have a lot of
hard drives and are looking to get more
someone should stay behind with a squad
redeploy on blake just in case it goes
bad keep in mind though there's a pretty
long squad redeploy timer and everyone
will definitely see you parachute back
in number 17 don't forget if you go down
but not out you drop hard drives you're
carrying if your squad comes out on top
remember to pick them back up likewise
scavenge enemy teams for their drives
number 18. remember how the blog said
only two teams can extract that's not
exactly true you can still get on the
condor in the down but not out state and
extract although you won't get credit
for the drives you dropped i imagine
also two squads can just not shoot each
other and both extract if they want and
if you do make it the game has
extraction streaks the impact of that is
that at the start of every round you
only get one tactical slot but the more
you extract the more tactical slots open
up each subsequent round and that lets
you buy more tools for each following
round that kind of incentivizes people
to take the first condor out if you're
playing battlefield 2042 we can't wait
to see what you find in hazard zone
seriously we got a lot of testing to do
so give us your best tips in the
comments below while you're at it don't
forget to head on over to gamespot's
youtube page to check out our review in
progress and with that let's leave you
with some gameplay of one intense
extraction we came across in our review
event thanks for watching
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
we'll do better next time
ah this is what i expected